オルメックのような言葉には鼻音がありませんが
、Gを削除すると鼻音がすべて失わ
れ、ガルカのような言葉でこれを見ることができます。オヌアクとゴクは
これらの2つの言葉でノーズプラグテストをもう一度試してください
ファックガクもう一度言うGは単独では
鼻音ではないので、mmが前に付いていない限り
、gigoogigoo
は常に鼻音なしで言う
必要があり
ます。 誰かがカガミやミール
を私に呼びかけているのを聞いたことがあります誰かがスゴイや信じられないほどのことを言っているのを聞いたことがあります
存在しない場合のG音の鼻の目のこの現象はベッタクールとして知られ
ていますが、よく似ていますが、それ
は昔の日本人のアーティファクトであり
、誰もがそれを一人で使用していた時代
がありましたが、これらのd
ビートだけを取り巻くルール
は非常に複雑で覚えにくいので、ニュースキャスターや40代以上の人々のスピーチでしか聞こえないでしょう。
これは、
この特定の問題に関する私の持ち帰りのポイントになります。
必然的に囲碁に遭遇したときに混乱
しないように、囲碁だけを知って
おく必要がありますが、
特に若い
場合は、前に述べたように、囲碁なしで
G音を生成するのが最善でない限り、再現について心配する必要はありません。
邪魔にならないように囲碁で大丈夫な
鼻音囲碁だけでなく、囲碁に関連する問題
をもう少し取得しましょうKとGについて話すとき、通常3つの
ことが起こります。